من الاردن طرحنا فرضيه وسالنا الناس اذا
قالوا لك ان هناك جهازا تسجل فيه صوتك
وافكارك يوميا ويجعلك تتواصل مع الناس عبر
الفيديو بعد الموت هل يمكن ان تستخدم هذا
الجهاز نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
لا بس ما لا ما راح استخدمه هذا الجهاز
لانه اييه في اشياء خاصه في ما بحب انه
الناس تعرف عنها مثلا ولو في رساله بدي
اوصلها لحدا اوصلها وانا عايشه مش انا ميت
بالنسبه
[موسيقى]
اه ممكن ليش لا يعني انه الخبرات الي انا
مريت فيها ممكن حدا يستفيد منها او يعدل
عليها ويمشي بطريقه اسلموا صح ممكن ورده
يعني
حتى في الافكار
انا في عندي افكار معينه لكن ما بحب الناس
انه هي بتعرف شو هي افكاري او شو كانت
نوايا او ما هو رايي بالضبط في كل
المواضيع يمكن بحب اسجلها لنفسي بس اني
استخدمها لجهاز انه بعدين بالمستقبل في
حدا غيري طلع عليه لا طبعا اكيد ما بحبها
يعني